Let's step back for a moment to talk
about the Android system architecture.
The Android framework offers lots of
useful classes to help you interact with
the system.
Think the activity of lifecycle or
device permissions, for example.
Or to help you access some type of
device functionality, like the camera or
the radios, like Wi-Fi or Bluetooth.
Sometimes, sensors like the gyroscope.
The path to accessing device hardware
from the framework comes together via
a series of layered abstractions.
What do I mean by that?
Each layer focuses on solving a bit of
the problem while the underlying layers
focus on solving subsequently
smaller problems until eventually,
with all the layers combined,
the desired functionality is achieved.
Now we won't go into heavy details
about what each layer does, but
we'll help you focus on the layers
you should be familiar with.
let's take a look.
You can think of a functioning
Android device as being made up of
different layers.
Now we've simplified this a tad
to focus on the essentials, but
feel free to check out
the link in the nodes for
an exhausted diagram on
the Android Open Source Project site.
The very top layer is
the application layer where
all the applications that
developers like you and I build.
Within our app,
we make use of the Android framework
classes like text view and activity.
And when we use these classes,
we can do some complex or
powerful things with
only a few lines of code.
In this case, we're displaying some
text or opening a new screen, for
example, but there's so much more.
So, how is this possible?
Well, the framework classes
are obstructing away unnecessary
complexity from us by calling into
the lower levels of Android and
relying on them to do the heavy lifting.
That is the tough and intricate job
of controlling a devices hardware.
Until eventually, it all works and this
is what we mean by layer obstructions.
The core operating system or an OS for
short has its own sophisticated code
to regulate how application and
system processes both access the limited
resources of the device hardware.
Now, applications running simultaneously
must share the resources of the device
in order to preserve the system's
overall usability and responsiveness.
The lowest layer is the actual
physical device hardware.
That is the silicone that makes up for
example the wireless radios,
like cellular, Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
The chips that control the screen and
then there's the CPU, the memory,
the GPU and much, much more.
These are the physical electronic
components that are packed in to
your device.
If you're going to
take away a one thing,
know that the beauty of these layers
is that they exist to simplify or
distract away the system's
complexity from US developer.
Allowing you to focus on making grade
apps that can leverage as much of
the device's hardware as possible.
So you can think of the framework,
as these clue between our app and
the device.
The framework classes allow us to
articulate how the device should behave
when a user is in our app.
Now, the framework compose of all
these Java classes that we see on
developer.android.com, as well
as some libraries written
in a programming language called C and
its relatives.
let's talk about a few examples of
how we've already relied on these
different layers without
even realizing it.
In our app code,
we've been calling the framework APIs.
So for example, when we were building
the Me Walk app, we were using the media
framework classes to play audio
from the speakers of the device.
In the current lesson, we're using
the HTTP URL connection class to
make network requests, which uses the
radio on the device to send packets of
information across the internet.
Now, we don't need to deal with
the Android Operating System directly.
Now, the framework classes are Java
classes that obstruct the implementation
details over what's happening
underneath in the hardware.
Now, the immediate player
in HTTP URL connection or
two examples of classes that use the
physical functionality of our Android
device by interacting
with framework classes.
There are many more examples
that you'll come across,
as you continue to learn more
about Android development.